people say to me oh Constantine you're
so brave for speaking out about this I
actually believe that
you believe that yeah
it's one of the reasons I want to have
you on
okay well what I say to those people are
you [__] mental what are you talking
about
what are you talking about
how is a brave my ancestor staff to
death and the gulags
what you think me expressing my opinion
in public is Brave
yeah why that's Insanity there's nothing
Brave about it it's my duty to say what
I think if I think that something is
wrong isn't it yes
so why is that brave uh just because
something is right doesn't mean that
it's not doesn't demand courage okay how
does it demand courage oh that's
interesting this doesn't feel like you
could possibly be asking me that
question I love it we are equally
thinking the other person is absolutely
out of their minds okay so uh here's how
I look at your life you are you are whip
it smart man and you are really
articulate and you could make a real
living even in the Soviet Union if you
just like turned a part of your brain
off that was like I'm either never gonna
talk about these things or I'm only
going to talk about them when I'm at
home and I will use the system to my
advantage I will work my way up which
you'd be very easily be able to do uh
because you can out think people so I
have a feeling if you had just a little
evil in you you could get people to
think things were their ideas that were
clearly yours uh you would manipulate
the [__] out of them you would rise to a
position of power and so you could do
all of that and now it would require you
to set aside your moral compass or not
have one or adopt one out of convenience
right which I I unfortunately think
humans are all too capable of doing so
the fact that you don't do any of that
the fact that you
um
are in a western country in a moment
where people really get a certain
religious
emotional
um righteousness out of tearing down
wrong think and the wrong people and it
makes them feel like they have done
something good
and it's a a sugar version of moral
virtue but it's still like something it
gives him a rush and so
now look you're not dumb so you've made
you've made a good living out of doing
that and I think your channel is only
going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger but
um
be cut in I'll say I'll say in a single
sentence why to me it's you seem Brave
uh you're a contrarian you don't mind
the conflict you actually posted a
hilarious photo of you maybe it was
video okay remember on Twitter it was
you with a machine gun and you said uh
uh it's like ready to open Twitter yeah
exactly exactly and I was like that's
[__] hilarious and then yeah I'm not
gonna do that because I hate that and my
audience this may not seem as weird to
you because this is the only time we sat
down across from each other my audience
is going to find this episode very weird
oh are they I've never done an episode
like this ever have you not never oh wow
so but you should have told me I would
have gone easy on them no this is great
I love it like I I will I would have lit
a candle you know did a little stroking
you know very kind no no no need but
it's um so anyway I when I see people
that are just completely unafraid to
roll up to Twitter with the machine gun
in hand I'm like all right you say what
you believe in you're standing for
something I think but what should I be
afraid of this is what I don't
understand
what is it that I'm supposed to be
afraid of a bunch of people I don't know
and don't respect on a social media
platform where they don't even show you
their face or name saying things about
me no you should fear what's happening
to Jordan Peterson he said he's in the
middle of 10 lawsuits as somebody that's
been in the middle of lawsuits let me
tell you what a toll they take on you
and maybe I'm too stupid and not brave
maybe that's you know I don't think
you're stupid but you might be naive to
something that is entirely possible and
as you crack it'll be interesting to see
what happens when you crack a million
Subs on YouTube it starts to get
different real fast yeah and what's
happening with Jordan where he's with
the whole bill c-16 which I can think of
no hotter like that's the nuclear core
and he came to prominence by latching on
to the nuclear core and he has said in
his very Jordan Peterson way that
um I if you arrest me I will uh if you
give me a final refuse to pay it if you
put me in jail I will go on a hunger
strike and I actually think he means it
I think he's so [__] stubborn that he
actually will and in the gulag
archipelago there's a great section from
Soldier knitson where he says it's
really interesting people come in you
get tortured Everybody Breaks actually
that's not true not everybody breaks and
the people that are so ideologically
like convicted they they will let you
kill them and they're all women and I
was like that is [__] hilarious going
back to what you were saying about men
and women being different and I just
thought that's my wife and that's Jordan
Peterson which he has said I have a more
feminine temperament like he just will
get something in his head and it
apparently no matter the amount of pain
that rains down on that man he just
keeps going and that doesn't look fun to
me
his life does not look fun to me
but I believe
you know Jordan isn't perfect he's a man
clearly and by the way I think he's
amazing but holy [__] uh does he
sometimes say things I'm like Jordan are
you trying to make your life suck like
that's a really dumb way to say that
but if we come back to the very
beginning of our conversation which is
about meaning and fulfillment
I couldn't be fulfilled using my
whatever you're very kind about my
intelligence and everything else using
that for things like that I
fundamentally
but I think are wrong right so that
reads is brave P.S no what that reads as
is not having a choice doesn't read as
Brave to you I get that I hear you but I
don't have a choice bravery is when
you're like well I could do this so I
could do that I'll do this I don't
really feel like I have a choice I feel
like I I you know it's weird that I I
have a background that's quite unusual
that is perfectly fitted to the cultural
moment of at the moment which is like I
was born in the Soviet Union I speak
Russian and English I understand both
cultures I can articulate myself pretty
well I grew up in Britain so I fit in
that culture I can see as an outsider
and likewise in America
um
you know I can make things funny if I
need to I can be serious if I need to
like it's a it's a skill set and a
background that not many people have
so what choice do I have would you be a
dissident in Russia yes yeah see [__] do
you know uh my whole family with
dissidents in Russia so like it's it's
not it's not a new thing that is very
interesting that's actually one of the
things that I wrote a piece on my sub
stack when my son was born
um
and I talked about a lot of this
you know
we come from generations of people who
who were killed for their beliefs
I'm not going to dishonor them
uh I'll say it again from where I'm
sitting that's Brave
I want to think that I would be as tough
I don't know if I'd be a dissident in
Russia that's just the honest answer and
it doesn't make me feel good about
myself but and the story I will tell
myself tonight is going to be that I
would